(logo slams)
- I'm in the fucking trenches.
I'm in Fortune, I'm in
Reddit, I'm in Discords,
I'm in Twitter. Like
I'm a fucking listener.
I'm just so fucking Jersey and loud
and fucking me that it confuses
the fuck out of people.
(upbeat music)
You got your perspective.
(crowd cheering)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
(upbeat music)
- All right Gary, so maybe
let's just start with
for those that don't know you
like the three people watching
who don't, just give us
kind of a real quick update
on who you are and how you
built such a large audience
and what you do on a day-to-day basis.
- Thanks Pomp. Bryce,
thanks for having me.
Immigrant from the Soviet Union,
kind of that scrapper
life, lemonade stands,
garage sailing, sports
cards, which are now back.
You know just kind of lived it in the 80s.
Parents were frugal and
poor and then middle class
and frugal and then upper
middle class and frugal.
So I'd always fight for
mine, buy my own Nintendo,
like at all my businesses.
Dad had a liquor store
dragged me in at 14,
fell in love with wine collecting,
launched an e-commerce
wine business in 1996.
One of the first in the country.
Became kind of a pioneer in that space.
Spent 22 to 34 building a
monster business for my parents.
Took their business from a
3.8 to a $60 million business.
Finally got to the place where
resentment started kicking in
and be like fuck I gotta
build something for myself.
My brother was graduating
college, let's do something.
We started an agency called VaynerMedia
that I'm still the active
CEO of, thousand people,
$200 million revenue business.
Invested along the way early
in Facebook, Twitter, Tumblr
and always built content
and always realized personal
brand was a leverage point
because I was capable of
building actual business.
I kind of almost a reverse
of this podcast, right?
Bryce and his contemporaries.
I see much more
thoughtfulness from this crew
than I did let's say from
the vine crew six years ago,
which is like it's not just
about getting that bag,
it's like, fuck let's make
sure we build something
along the way.
You know, 80% Pomp, Bryce
of that crew is just actually
not going to be capable
of being an entrepreneur, which is okay.
Hopefully they'll find
COO's, they'll find investors
they'll find partners.
They'll be thoughtful.
20% are actually me in reverse, right?
I was an operator. Nobody
on earth knew who I was
when I was 30, fucking four years old.
And then I built awareness and brand
and now siphon it back into
my business capabilities.
And in a lot of ways, I'm hopeful
that a lot of the creators
on TikTok right now
and other places play
the reverse game of me.
I didn't say a word
and have no leverage from a personal brand
but as an operator, they're the reverse.
They have a lots of words
a ton of audience, a ton of leverage.
And if they're thoughtful
and become operators
or become thoughtful with
who they partner with
they can build institutional
generational wealth.
And so that's why I
said yes to the podcast
because I'm hot on this topic
because I want these kids to win instead
of living Gary Coleman life, right?
- So you're known on social media
for actually giving advice
kind of like just how you,
how you did right there.
(Bryce chuckles)
Why do you always give away your secrets
for free as far as influencers,
marketing and advertising.
- A combination, Bryce of the following
talent, because I have enough
talent to have the next idea
and the next idea, and the next idea.
I'm not crippled by like,
this is my one thing, my one moment.
Two, legacy.
Like I genuinely like that I,
I know both of you, very,
very, very lightweight.
And I'm very grateful
that as we get to know each other more
for real through serendipity
or more importantly,
as you've talked to the
people closest to you
that know me the best, they
have the nicest things to say
about me versus people who've
only seen me on the internet.
So reputation and legacy
matter to me a lot.
And if I could be kinder better, stronger,
historically correct it
builds reputation, aka brand.
Right? And then just kind of like
that selfish, selfless game of this.
Like it feels nice, Bryce.
Like admiration comes in
a lot of different forms.
There's a lot of people that like you
'cause you're attractive to them.
That's just real talk.
And that's cool.
I didn't have that luckiness that you had.
Other people love LeBron
because of how he can play basketball.
For me, I have a very different community
because I'm built on admiration.
People, as a matter of fact,
a lot of people aren't
even sure if I'm for real
at first or full of shit
but people tend to be sticky
with me and about me and I about them
on the merit of the advice I've given.
I mean, there's a lot of
kids running around right now
that have made an
incredible amount of money
on sports cards 'cause
they bought 40 Lukas
for $35 because they
were part of my community
and sold them for $1,500.
And that's just a very big thing
that happened to their lives
and they trusted me because
I always did the right thing
by them, including this.
And so for me, it's just
all I've been taught
as a kind of old school
immigrant kid like reputation.
What do people say behind your back,
spit on your hand, shake a hand, do that,
do the right things.
I like being liked.
You know, I want to be
a great entrepreneur
and I think that comes in
a lot of shapes and sizes.
Some will just be Jeff Bezos
and Oprah Winfrey and just immerse wealth.
Others like me, I'd like a mass wealth.
I'd like, you know, it's tough to listen
to somebody who didn't
do it for themselves
but I love that there's a
different relationship I have
with the audience than most entrepreneurs
that are of my ilk.
- You like helping out people.
That's, that's what your brand is.
- It's just nice, it's, you know
your brand becomes your
actions to your point.
There are people in high
school and junior high
in my career long before
there was any persona
that I've come out through
the years and be like,
"Well, he was doing this for me
over a drink 10 years ago".
That's exactly right. It feels nice.
I have something to give.
I feel almost guilt and gratitude
that I have something to give.
So fuck it. I'm going to get it.
- So what's one piece of advice you'd give
to young entrepreneurs watching this
or even social media
people that want to start.
- Most people live in high
school until they die.
So what's holding back so
many of you right this minute
from starting out honey,
I actually mean honey.
Like you grew up with your
grandma as a kid making honey
in the backyard.
You like honey, you see
this whole DTC happening
but you're too cool on TikTok.
And you think if you started a honey brand
people are gonna make fun of you.
Literally, that's what me
fucks me up or anything, right?
Pomp, heavy in crypto but
has this passion for surfing
and people might say
to him that are smart,
"You're distracted.
Pomp you're distracted.
You've got this moment".
But he just likes it.
He just wants to start
a surf board company.
My advice is get the out of high school.
Other people's opinions
on your life just don't fucking matter.
They don't play out.
It never plays out.
You never on your death bed are thrilled
that you listen to everybody else.
You become, you resent it.
And so my number one advice is like
if you want to do something, do it.
If you're so fucking cool,
they'll probably follow you.
I got fucking laughed out
with a sports card thing.
Now the fucking coolest people
in culture are fucking
flexing sports cards
on social media.
Literally, 36 months ago
the coolest people I knew,
the smartest people I knew,
the richest people I
knew were on some shit
behind my back. Of like,
"He's going crazy".
Like "What the is the
matter with this dude?
Why is he doing this? This
is stupid, this is dorky".
Dah, dah, dah, dah, dah, dah, dah, dah.
All of those people are
texting me every day.
Where do I get a Jordan PSA 10?
Should I buy the Charizard?
What should I do about Magic bird?
It just sold for over 700,000.
When you told me to buy, it was 40,000.
Like, is this over?
Is it too late?
Like, and I'm talking like top 10 athletes
top 10 hedge fund
managers, top 10 TikTokers.
Like, if you believe in it
and you're fucking about it
and it makes you happy,
it will always work out.
- Gary, one of the things
that's really interesting
I think is most people
know you as an operator
you then had a epic run.
A lot of people don't
probably realize how great
of an angel investor you
were in kind of early 2010's
and number of hits you had.
It seems like you've kind
of swung back to operating.
And then now into baseball
cards, is it just the natural
like what you're interested
in is how you balance
out between operating and investing
or is there some kind of
method to the actual madness
of how you balance those two things?
- First of all, it's a
really thoughtful question.
I'm flattered for you paying
attention to that level.
It's really, it's truly,
I mean it. Thank you.
First I wanted to give back to my parents.
Bro, when I tell you being a Soviet Jew
you know, the math around
me ending up in America
and I'm such a fucking entrepreneur.
Can you imagine me
growing up in communism?
That would have been like, who the fuck?
I would have drank so
much vodka at 11 years old
I would have been sad.
So first it was like
I got to operate this
thing for my parents.
'Cause I'm a raw talent.
Like at 22, I knew who I was, right?
I'm going to the hall of
fame. Like I believed it.
I just, I don't know
what else to tell you.
So I fuck with Kobe and LeBron
like I get it being a child and knowing.
And I wanted to put that
energy first to my parents.
'cause I love them the most.
I felt like I needed to.
I had to, it was the
right fucking thing to do.
My mom was the best fucking mother.
My dad worked every fucking minute.
Like, you know, so, and then I was like
then I like, you know, getting paid 60, 70
80,000 a year when you're
building a 20, 30, 40 million
you're you're getting fucked, right?
You don't own the business.
And fuck, if I was doing it for you Pomp
you'd be paying me a
half a million a year.
So you're double fucked
when you're the kid building up business
for your family business.
All the kids out there
listening right now.
I know you're getting fucked.
I know that you're not
getting paid enough.
And I know you're the reason
a business is exploding
and you don't own it.
And your parents say
they'll leave it to you
but you're going to pay inheritance tax
and it feels fucked up.
Trust me.
It's okay. You got time
in your 30s, 40s, 50s
to get yours if you're so fucking good.
So Pomp, I had to do that
and then I had like 150 saved, 250 saved
'cause I lived like shit.
Like I'm the reverse of the (indistinct)
Like all these kids, I'm envious.
I'm happy for them.
Truly, I am because I lived like shit.
I worked 15 hours a day.
I didn't have anything.
Like I was giving up
my 20s for my parents.
So then I was like, fuck.
You get this little
resentment thing going.
You don't really resent your parents.
You're like, just like, man,
you wanted to do this, but like fuck.
Like, you know,
it sounds good at 22 but now I'm 31
I don't, I've done these
incredible accomplishments
and I have eight fucking dollars.
It kind of, you know, fucks with you.
I see social, at that
point it was so right
about YouTube, Email, Google ad words.
I started having confidence
that I was more than a retailer
because that's how I thought of myself.
I'm like, "Fuck, I know what
people are going to do".
You know, you gave me
a very flattering tweet
the other day about,
you know, 2014 Bitcoin
and sports cards three years before.
And like early at shit that
sometimes I don't bet enough.
There's a million different things
that have happened in my career but I,
until the day I die, I know
I'm going to be good at this.
And I, I expect my wealth
creation to get very aggressive
in my 50s and 60s where I'm less passive
about my age and patience.
Where I'm going to be probably
a little more aggressive.
However, I knew that I needed
to catch up to my skillset
and I went high risk on
Facebook, Twitter and Tumblr
because I was as competent as I am today
about Michael Jordan's rookie card, right?
On the record, so it's documented
it's probably going to close
this week at a $300,000 card.
There's 0.0 chance that it's
not a million dollar card
including global financial meltdown.
So good, it'll go back down to 170
but within a five to seven
year window on the rebound
that is going to be a million dollar card.
'Cause there's enough demand now
to justify against the 317 units.
You know, I love when the
Bitcoin community talks
about 21 million or is that
the number about right?
I agree with that.
I'm like, is that yep.
They fucking got it.
This is not printing in
perpetuity, supply and demand.
I understood what was
happening with social.
I bet the farm.
Then I realized,
Oh fuck, I might be the best at this.
Like I need to see if I am.
Am I the best at just genuinely
understanding not only
who Bryce is earlier than most people
not only who DaBaby is
earlier than anybody,
not only Clubhouse earlier than anybody,
not only, like I now do this
in so many arenas
culture, business, human.
Let me build a death
star, I'm the emperor.
This real talk now,
this is literally how
it went through my mind.
I'm the emperor, right?
I'd like to be a little bit more Yoda
'cause the emperor loses in the end.
But the emperor, let me build a death star
which has Vayner X that
is so big and so scalable
that I can do sports cards
and a direct to consumer wine brand
and buy 50% of Puma and
build non fungible tokens
which I believe in heavily
right now and all these things
at the highest level.
Because if it's just me,
I'm going to be able to do one thing.
I know me, I'm self-aware.
I need chaos and my hands in 30 pots
to be happy.
Six will fail but fucking
24 are gonna succeed
and I'm gonna be happy.
And so that's what I've been building.
So I ate shit this last decade
and built a death star.
And now you're just starting
to see me kind of pop my head up
and point it, right?
Do I want to point it
to get awareness for Crohn's disease?
'Cause AJ wants that.
Do I want to point it to my homies
that now want to go into politics
and make sure they win the governorship?
Do I want to point it against
my Vayner sports athletes?
My Vayner talent, talents.
I think in the last two or three years
I felt the undercurrent of
some people starting to say,
"Wait a minute,
Gary might be a little
smarter than we thought".
Whereas like six years ago it was like,
"He's just a persona.
Like he is what he is".
And I'm flattered by that.
I'm also concerned in a weird, funny way.
'Cause I've loved being
underrated a little bit.
Even for my overrated Gary V part,
I knew I was underrated as Gary Vaynerchuk
and I knew that was actually my leverage
to building out what I'm building out.
And I finally think
that people are starting to figure it out.
And I think my next two decades are going
to be super interesting.
- How long have you been into the cards?
- From 1986 to 1993,
it was my entire life.
I did cards heavy.
It's how I made my money.
Like my friends made
fun of me to not going
to like the cool party,
like my sophomore year of high school
to go to like a mall and set up a table.
Like it was a real passion of mine.
I popped back in for 40 seconds in 2003
'cause I thought LeBron was
going to be Michael Jordan.
So I bought a ton of LeBron packs
and got a bunch of LeBrons.
And then three years ago,
three and a half years ago
I just do what I do on
how I knew who you were
before you even popped.
How I knew DaBaby and Meg
Thee Stallion and Gunna.
- You DM'd me.
I don't know if you
remember but you DM'd me
and you like you texted,
you said keep pushing bro.
That was like-
- I know it.
Bryce, I know it's super well
because I love encouraging kids.
'Cause I never know if
the person knows who I am
or don't when I do that for kids.
But I know if they google it
that might just be a spot
because I know the come up
for athletes, rappers, influencers.
And I know I might just catch you
on the one day where like
you get a negative comment
or have something go down.
Where you're just like, fuck this shit.
And I'm always hopeful
that when I do that for somebody
that it just gives them a charge
of like, no, no let me refocus.
Like there's something here.
So I try to give karma like that.
Like I think most people
that are smart like me
see somebody like you
and they want to manage you.
They want to get money out of you.
They want to sign you for
a five-year ironclad deal.
I try to go the reverse
back to what I said
earlier about reputation.
I'm just trying to fucking bring value.
I remember it like yesterday.
You want to hear something better Bryce
that you'll even give me more credit
of knowing?
- Yeah.
- That was probably after nine months
of knowing who you are, right?
Like, because I also want
to make sure I get a
little read for the part.
Like, so I basically
that I have this thing
I think it's starting
to become more obvious.
It's going to be really weird
to see what it plays out
as I'm an old man.
Because am I going to be
at a place where at 67 where I'm like,
"The Colorado Rockies is
a good real estate thing".
And is that like, I have to be careful
'cause I'm a little worried
that as my reputation builds
that I'll be in this weird new place
where am I going to trick
myself into something?
'Cause I know the economic impact
the second I say a word hat.
Like I really am
thoughtful about this shit
but nonetheless long-winded way to say,
it was thoughtful Pomp.
I knew that I had something.
So I said, let me operate
so that I can layer a SPAC.
I can layer a fund.
Like, and I needed to
build family Pomp, right?
I have 25 to 40 people around me
who've now been with me
for seven years close
who are like my internal
family who can be the heads of.
- When you think through
kind of why you're able
to see some of this stuff
some of it is absolutely just a skill.
It's all the intangible things
that just make you you.
What are the things
that you look for though to confirm it?
Because I think that what
you're really highlighting is
like, hey, sometimes I have an intuition
but I could trick myself.
I could also get a false positive
by simply just saying,
"Gary believes, you know,
X is going to be big".
- [Gary] Yeah.
- And then it kind of becomes
big in the short term.
So how do you actually gut check yourself
or make sure that you're right on.
- I don't want anybody
to make a split video
that I make about myself.
Like, look what I said
when I was fat in the head.
Let's say like, I don't need that video.
I don't need that video.
And so it scares the out of me.
The second there's a
video that Bryce can do
that says, "Hey guys",
and which would be right.
"Don't just fucking
blindly listen to Gary B,
watch this". And I'm like, you know,
"Care bears are coming back"
and he's like, "Where did fucking care..."
Like I'm so petrified of being wrong Pomp
because I'm so smart about
brand and reputation, I believe.
And I'm honorable, like
honor matters, right?
Like I'm pumped about
like how I do my shit.
Like people make speculations
about me and cards.
Like he pumps and dumps.
He says that I haven't
sold a fucking the card.
That's just the truth.
Show me the receipt.
I'll be like, good luck, good.
You know, like it's
really easy for me to like
I need to put my head on my pillow.
I'm too far along in my
reputation at this point
I'm just in the precipice
of getting my respect.
When LeBron said, "I want my respect too"
when he won the title this
year, I'll be very frank.
It, it rolled through my body.
I know where I'm at
but I also know that I'm wildly underrated
in my own feelings about me.
And I don't want to do
anything to fuck that up.
I've got to keep executing
for next 30 years
exactly how I've been.
And I'll put myself right
where I want to be on.
Like I put my heart on the field.
'Cause I think of
entrepreneurship like sports.
So it's really easy for me.
It's why I don't have a lot
of those losses Pomp, right?.
So that's how I think about it.
I get a lot of flack for
interrupting when I'm on podcast.
When I do podcasts, when
I do my own, as you know
'cause you're in the
Bitcoin space, I get picks
and I get I'm getting thrilled
by the BTC community on that.
What's ironic about that,
I always laugh is if people realized 97%
of my life is listening,
it's just when I pop up
and do a podcast like this,
I'm so pent to want to talk
because I've been thinking
and listening for so long.
I think it's because I listened more
than fucking anybody, bro.
I'm in the trenches.
I'm in Fortune, I'm in
Reddit, I'm in Discords.
I'm in Twitter, I'm,
like, I'm a fucking listener.
I'm just so Jersey and loud
and me that it confuses the out of people.
But I think about listening everybody.
Everyone's looking at data
that has already been manipulated.
I'm looking at raw data
and then using my natural
talent to make my intuition
and speculations, which
have been tried and true
for a long time now.
- I have a question,
for someone like you what is
the definition of success?
- My life is based on
how many people show up
to my funeral and what
is said when I'm dead.
The definition of success
for me is the legacy.
It's funny, I was with a father today
when I dropped off my kids at school
and he's a big hockey fan
and Winnipeg Jets fan.
So we have that Jets thing
we always kind of laugh.
We were talking about hockey
and I said to him, you know,
in 1992, three and four
I watched 80 to 90%
of the entire Rangers games.
The only time I did it
was when I was going back
and forth 'cause the Knicks were on too.
And then they won the cup in 94
and I literally stopped watching them.
And then I said to him
"And I stopped watching the Yankees
after 96 when they won".
I have a very close friend
who's extremely close
friends with Derek Jeter
and we've had some jams through the years
and I always tell him how sad I am
that I didn't really get
to appreciate his career
because I kind of checked
the fuck out in 96
and I didn't really run with it.
But I'm the biggest
Jets fan and Knicks fan.
I go crazy.
So I realized, Oh my God,
I'm a thrill of the hunt guy, right?
I'm in it for the journey,
not the fucking trophy.
It's why my biggest business
accomplishments, right?
Rezzi which I co-founded,
co-created helped operate got,
like really was in there.
It's a monster win.
Nobody associates me with
that nine figure exit.
K Swiss is reversed.
People see the Gary V part
but I was in there, operation.
Empathy wines, I just sold it recently.
Huge exit for direct to
consumer brand in 18 months.
Honestly, nobody's thinking about that.
So a lot of people are like,
"Gary, he's just full
of shit. He's a talker"
because I don't pump my own
business accomplishments.
Mainly 'cause I don't give a fuck, Bryce
what anybody talks.
Whether, like I judge
people on how they judge me.
So when I see Pomp put out that text,
I'm like, "Oh, this fucker's listening".
When him and his brothers
saying those nice things
about me and AJ, they're
paying further attention
than people in the ecosystem.
How do I know that?
A, that was very nice of them
and not needed for them to say that.
B, Pomp's fucking
executing it in his space.
So for me
I want the smartest people
to think I'm good and nice.
I want the people that
actually know me in real life
and can speak to something in
detail to think I'm the best.
I don't need the crowd.
The whole team will
loose the basketball team
when the other team goes on a 17-0 run.
You know, when a team
starts a basketball game
and they're at home and
we're back in the crowd
when I go back to the garden
and the first fucking game I go to.
The Bucks go on a 12-0
run to start the game
And I think about that everyday Bryce.
That people cheering or booing me
that have no idea who I am
have no idea anything
besides what I put out there.
I put that out there.
It's my fault that I get excited
when I'm in conversations,
I interrupt people.
They're right.
The person that says
I'm a dick face is right
because they're experienced in that way.
Like that's their perception
but I have to know what's underneath that.
And we all do.
And I think that's what
helps people navigate
having too much notoriety.
I can't imagine Bryce,
the shit that's gone
through your head in the
last 24 months of your life.
That's a lot of attention and opinion.
But if you're grounded in knowing
that you're a good person
and that you have good intent
and that you're human
and you'll make flaws.
And when you do, they're
gonna shit all over you.
As long as they're not real
fucking crazy shit that like
you know, like it's one
thing to misstep like a human
it's another thing to do a crime
or like suppress somebody like bad shit.
And I know I'm that person. I got lucky.
I got the right DNA, I
got the right parenting.
My shit is never going to be fucking fraud
or fucking like shit that should put me
in jail or...
It's going to be like
maybe I'm too loose with a statement.
And people lost the context.
I'm like, "Oh fuck. Sorry,
what I really meant..."
You know. So I'm cool.
And so for me
it's just living that life
and that's what works for me.
And because I'm good
inside, I can then send you
that DM without wanting
anything in return.
My life was based on legacy.
How much love am I going to get?
And what's really crazy about it, Bryce
because I think about the all the time
which is like this is so fucked up.
The thing I'm living my entire life
for is something I'll never say.
It's so fucked up. Like I,
I always asked myself like,
like I'm like, "Is this good?
Is this like the most noble?
Is this super fucked up.
Am I fucked up dude?".
Like, like it's crazy to me.
The thing that drives me is
like almost in a weird way
the thing I don't give
a fuck about, right?
'Cause if I don't give
a fuck about opinions
like who gives a shit if they give you
a statue or not?
I just genuinely like being liked
by the people who actually know me.
I like people so fuck...
It's funny.
My friends always make fun
of me for not liking animals.
And it's not that I don't like dogs.
It's just that I like people
so much more like so much more.
Like so much more.
And I think that is something
I think a lot about.
That people love their animals
because there's no feedback loop, right?
It's unconditional love.
Or if it's not, you don't even know it.
And people don't like people
because there is a feedback loop.
But for me, I'm too empathetic
to the other person on the other line.
When somebody's shitting on me on social
I'm like, "Man, this dude is so unhappy
that he had to come to my fucking page
watch my video and leave
some dog shit on me.
I'm not mad for me, or
sad for me. or mad at him.
I feel bad for him. I love him.
Like I wish he was in a better...
Like, I don't have time
to do anything other than what I did
for you Bryce, right?
I don't have time
to do anything other
than what I just did Pomp
which is saying fanatically, "Thank you.
That was very nice of you
and made me feel nice.
Thank you for doing that".
I'm paying attention
to only positivity,
optimism and practicality.
That's my poop.
My poop is positivity,
optimism and practicality.
Not the fucking shit that people drop
on other people 'cause they're
actually hurting inside.
Nobody who's ever shitting
on people ever fazes me
because they're fucking emotionally weak.
You got time to shit on someone?
You're in a bad place.
- Gary, one of the concepts
that I've been thinking a lot
about lately is this idea
of like a time billionaire.
Someone who always talks
about billionaire says
"Having a billion dollars"
but a time billionaire is essentially
a billion seconds is
about 31 years, right?
And so a million seconds
is like 11 days.
- Yeah, love that.
Love that.
- A billion seconds
is 31 years.
And so I heard this on Tim
Ferris had a guy come on
and he was talking about this.
And so the whole idea is like
Bryce's basically a two time
time billionaire, right?
He's got 62 years
- Pomp.
- Of his life at least.
You and I don't have that.
Maybe we got one.
(Pomp laughs)
- So how do you think-
- Pomp.
Pomp, I love you.
I love you. I fucking love you.
I say it differently.
I think every kid
that fucks with me is tired
of me saying patience.
They all want to fucking
punch me in the face.
They're like, "Fuck you dude".
Like the comedians that spook
me on TikTok are so funny.
They're like, like person comes up
"Gary, I'm 91". You got fucking time.
Like, you know, like I'm such a buyer
of this thesis Pomp.
I haven't heard that time billionaire
but I fucking, I'm about that.
Like, yeah.
It's what, when they DM like
"Yo keep pushing" leads to me
and Bryce having dinner in LA.
If it wasn't COVID, which would
have, it would have happened
that whole dinner would have been like,
"Kid, listen to me.
I would rip my arms, legs
and give you all my money to be your age".
It's that fucking real to me.
Time is optimism.
Like I don't even think
a kid should even begin
to get serious other than tasting shit
and trying shit until they're 30.
Like don't even think about it.
Take 18 to 30 or 22 to 30
depending on parent college life
and fucking taste, try, explore.
Like having your shit together? Fuck that.
You're, like that's rules
of when people died at 38 years old.
The rules of dying at a hundred
which is what's going to happen
to fucking Bryce need to
be about, be strategic
and learn about yourself
at fucking 18, 22 to 30.
How do I think about it?
It's the greatest gift.
Assuming that this is very young
given Bryce's audience who's listening.
You fuckers are winning.
You guys fucking have it.
Fuck what I have or you
can't wait to have a yacht
or you want to make
money so you can hook up
with a pretty girl or boy
or like, fuck all that.
You have time.
- So when you think through
it, if you could go back
and be Bryce at 21, you've
got a massive audience.
Everyone's paying attention.
The good and the bad that comes with that.
What are the moves that you're
at least thinking through
and considering if you're
sitting in his seat right now?
Knowing that you want
to be an entrepreneur
and an investor not
just social media star.
- If you want to be an
entrepreneur and investor
I think you go work for
somebody humbly for a year.
That is your dream person.
Bryce could shoot for the fucking moon.
Go after Bezos.
Maybe right this minute,
somebody in his life is like,
"Jeff you need to be
way more contemporary".
And the thought of Bryce being an intern
for contemporariness
so he can shadow Jeff.
But Jeff can get the 411
on the streets from Bryce.
I'll tell you Bob Kraft.
I mean, I fucking hate the pats.
Everyone knows that but
Bob Kraft does that.
That's why he with Meek
Mill, with Michael Rubin.
That's why wears Air Force 1s.
(Gary chuckles)
It's probably subconsciously
and I don't want
to make this assumption inappropriate
but he also dates young.
Like to me, if I'm Bryce
and all those that I see
like the 55 that are like him,
I would fucking, whether it's Bezos,
whether it's Diddy, whether Jay Z
whether it's somebody even more rigid.
Like, you know, obviously
there's the famous ones
but maybe if he's super
aware that it's fashion
and his favorite CEO's a little
bit more under the radar.
It's not Virgil.
It's actually the CEO of Reebok
because he just likes to work.
I'm pretty sure everyone's saying
"Yes, you can shadow me
and siphon through osmosis,
a fucking real MBA.
Not that horseshit that you'll pay for.
And I'll siphon from
you knowing who the fuck
the people are that are actually matter
in the world right now
for everybody under 25.
To me, that's the great
trade of society right now.
Listen, I'm at the top of my craft.
I'd have to if Bezos emails me and is like
"Yo, intern for me for a year".
Like even I'm like, I probably wouldn't.
I'd be like, I don't want to bullshit you
but fuck, I would sit on that for a week
and be like, you know.
So whoever that is
for that kid right now,
don't do the famous one.
Like, Oh, okay. It's Elon
or it's fucking like...
Take a step back and listen, Elon's both.
So you gotta take that
app out if you can get it
but maybe it's somebody
a little more boring
but really fucking doing it.
And then it goes to who the fuck are you?
Like if you know that you're famous now
but actually you want to
you want to actually wrap
up everybody one day.
Well then it's Michael Omit.
Maybe it's Ari, right at WME.
Like, like there's a trade
there for those kids.
There's a trade.
Pomp are you doing any sports card shit?
- I'm doing it.
- I'm doing Pokemon cards.
- Bryce, I'm telling you right now.
And I think I, I think I
said this to Josh Richard
somebody's gonna win the
TikTok sports card thing
And it's going to really matter.
Like it's fucking there for the taking.
Like be educated
because if you're saying
dumb shit it's going
to always, back to what I said earlier.
Like talk about what you know
but when I tell you this
thing is really happening
not kind of, it's really happening.
Do you like sports Bryce?
- I'm not really into sports now.
- Then go deep into Pokemon.
- Yeah, Pokemon is
really interesting to me.
I don't know why.
(Bryce laughs)
- You should get-
- I grew up with that stuff.
- Brother, you should get
real, real, real educated
because the fractionalization
market is going
to take the super premium
to the fucking moon.
- That's fantastic.
- I'm super,
I'm super over already.
I'm happy to do part
two another time, guys.
- Oh, 100% and thank you
so much for coming on.
- YouTube watchers,
what's up. It's Gary V.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration
of YouTube is about to
explode stories, polls
more content, more engagement,
more surprise and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it
and I hope I see you soon.